hey everyone I'm Andrea your real-life
English fluency coach and today we have
a great lesson for you where you'll be
learning lots of slang vocabulary and
expressions that natives use in real
life with songs by Bruno Mars runo Mars
has sold over 130 million records
worldwide making him one of the
best-selling music artists of all time
now you're going to have a lot of fun
with this lesson and you'll understand
natives a lot better by watching it now
before we get into today's lesson I want
to let you know that every week here on
learn English with TV series we make
lessons just like this one to help you
learn English without getting lost
without missing the jokes and without
subtitles
in fact Gladys says that she loves
learning with our channel because she
can smile and relax whilst learning
pronunciation and vocabulary so if that
sounds good to you don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and the belt down
below so that you don't miss a single
lesson the first Bruno Mars song we'll
look at is locked out of heaven
[Music]
if you put or lay something on the line
you risk it
this is often co-located with a life as
in the following example heroism can't
be measured by a piece of metal but what
else can we do to recognize the brave
officers that have put their lives on
the line sometimes to make this sound
more emphatic we might say to put it all
on the line like Bruno Jim here is also
using this expression to describe his
feelings you don't even know she's
single now no it's just I kind of put it
all on the line twice actually and she
said no Bruno is saying here he's not
willing to put his heart on the line he
means that he doesn't want to have his
heart broken so how did you get that far
in to law school and a dropout well I
got my heart broken yeah and then
everything got weird this song has many
references to religion and worshipping
a sinner is one that commit sins or does
something that is against the rules of a
religion the expression will take a
deeper look at is to change one's ways
this means to improve one's behavior
habits or beliefs in the context of this
line in the song Bruno is telling the
woman he has such strong feelings for
her that she could make him change his
behavior in a positive way let's watch
this expression in use previously on
Desperate Housewives and Carlos promised
to change his old ways masterpiece is a
work done with extraordinary skill
example this building is a masterpiece
this song is a masterpiece however here
he's using this word to praise or say
nice things about women by the way did
you notice the strange grammar in the
sentence them good girls shouldn't it be
those good girls or the good girls this
is an interesting slang use of the
objective personal pronoun them so if
you say for example I got to get them
tickets you mean I got to get their
tickets remember this is very informal
and you should only talk like this in
appropriate situations then he says
he uses the word style as a verb this is
not a common use and is also slang an
approximate definition could be showing
that you have style
continuing with the slang by wiling he
means dancing enthusiastically or
partying
[Applause]
[Music]
then he says living it up in the city to
live it up means to have a very
enjoyable time especially by going to
parties or having a very busy social
life I'm gonna drag it out
yeah you're gonna live it up while I can
right do you want to master native
vocabulary and pronunciation then I
highly recommend our fluent with friends
cause in this forty eight week course
you will learn with the first two
seasons of friends
you'll receive PDF power lessons
vocabulary memorization software access
to our fluency circle global community
and so much more and did you know that
you can try it right now for free with
our three-part master class all you have
to do is click up here or in the
description box below to learn more and
sign up now if you sexy then flaunt it
can you already work out the meaning of
flaunt there let's watch these three
clips if you're still in doubt I was I
really wasn't gonna flaunt this I have
made a very sizable donation to Oscars
nephews walkathon 25 dollars the point
that didn't work with him in penny need
to out of deference to them let's not
flaunt our happy relationship
you have a keen insight into the human
heart Amy Farrah Fowler do you know that
I have lost 68 pounds in two years that
is fantastic what I've got
you can flaunt 2/3 of the day outside of
the officer if you think that flaunt
means to show or display your
possessions abilities or qualities to
obtain other people's admiration you got
it it's similar to this other word he
uses brag about something George Michael
was trying to impress a cousin he was
tutoring in math by bragging about
software he was developing so it's
privacy software that's also anti-piracy
it's called fakeblock he was lying
it was software that made a phone when
tapped sound like a wood block by if you
freaky then own it he means to accept
who you are even with your flaws or
defects you're probably familiar with
own as in he owns a car an alternative
meaning of this is when we say something
like own who you are or accept who you
are or own it take responsibility for a
mistake we often turn this into the
phrasal verb own up will you make a
mistake all you can do is own up to it
all right
because it's something you can't fix
in grenade Bruno talks about a woman
he's in love with and all the things he
would do for her what should Seoul
understand is a grenade
I jump in front of a train
you know he says he'd do anything for
her this is the most generic of all
these ways that you can use to show
extreme loyalty or appreciation for
someone then you'll observe the same
meaning in the idiomatic expression take
a bullet in other words you care so much
about someone that you would die to save
their life example we've been friends
forever
I'd take a bullet for him if you're
enjoying watching this lesson with Bruno
Mars and you love learning English with
songs then I highly recommend you check
out our playlist because we have so many
more lessons just like this one with
lots of different artists all you have
to do is click up here or in the
description box below to have a look and
choose your next lesson now we move from
the Bruno who would do anything for
someone to the Bruno who doesn't feel
like doing anything today I don't feel
like doing anything I just wanna lay in
my bed this is the lazy song
[Music]
the phrasal verb kick your feet up is
quite visual can you guess in which of
these the person kicked their feet up we
say this to talk about a moment when we
want to relax a very useful informal
word that we love to use instead of
relaxed is chill let's watch some clips
with this word hey Schmidt how you doing
can I sit with you on your cooler here
yeah just chilling
hang with the cat I love to tell someone
to relax we say chill out because you're
weak Nick weak-ass muggy is a type of
rope as seen in this picture your old
man is your father if I could only save
one possession and fire probably my
first set of golf clubs my old man came
to me he then uses another fun way to
refer to his father pops in American
slang some people also say mums to refer
to their mother but not my old woman
just to strut is to walk in a proud way
trying to look important the way that
models walk down a catwalk if she's
doing something that's making Leonard
uncomfortable you should talk to her oh
no he's not uncomfortable at all no he's
loving it yeah he's strutting around
like he's five foot six
continuing in line with the lazy theme
he won't even get dressed if you're in
your birthday suits you're naked
hang loose is also similar to chill if
you let things hang loose you relax and
don't worry about them because they're
not important here he also means he'll
be hanging loose as he won't be wearing
any underwear
my pride my ego my needs and my selfish
ways
waise here is similar to when we defined
to change ones ways it refers to how a
person often behaves we often say an
adjective + ways we also often say stuck
in one's ways or set in one's ways why
are you doing sitting in front of a be
equal J says I can't leave until I taste
it why do you torture him like these
because he's too stuck in his ways
Gloria this is good for him he'll taste
the pickle he'll find that he likes it
he'll try more things this is good
parenting my ego my needs and my selfish
ways
cause the good strong woman like you to
walk out my life
[Music]
and it haunts me yeah but my clothes
this word is a bit different from the
type of vocabulary we've been seeing so
far you could say this word is more
related to the horror theme for example
if a ghost haunts you it visits you or
appears in front of you frequently and
it makes you feel scared or think about
a haunted house for example the use here
is a bit less literal we often talk
about a certain memory haunting you
meaning you constantly think about it
and you start to feel anxious I was
thinking unhooking them last week I
tried to take one off a girl at a party
I'm humbled for so long she started to
laugh it still haunts me
[Music]
[Applause]
just killed a man
put a gun against easy pulled my trigger
now
[Music]
mama
I fit just
[Music]